نقلت رويترز عن مسؤول في الاستخبارات
الباكستانيه ان الجيش الباكستاني نفذ
اليوم ضربات لاستهداف مسلحين بلوش داخل
ايران وكان المساعد الامني لمحافظ سيستان
وبلوشستان في ايران قال ان دوي انفجارات
سمع صباح اليوم في اطراف مدينه راوان جنوب
شرقي البلاد بالقرب من الحدود الباكستانيه
واضاف ان الجهات الامنيه بالمنطقه قد تبحث
في اسباب هذه الانفجارات وكانت ايران دمرت
قبل يومين قاعدتين
لجماعه جيش العدل للمسلحين البلوش في
باكستان بعد استهدافهما بصواريخ ومسيرات
الخارجيه الباكستانيه الان تعلن ان
باكستان نفذت سلسله ضربات عسكريه على
مخابئ ارهابيين في اقليم سيستان وبلوشستان
الايراني معنا من استان مباد مدير مكتب
الجزيره عبد الرحمن مطر ومن طهران مراسل
الجزيره نور الدين غير نبدا معك عبد
الرحمن مرحبا بكم في
البدايه عبد الرحمن تفاصيل هذا البيان
الخارجيه الباكستانيه والمناطق التي
استهدفت بيان الخارجيه الباكستانيه يتحدث
عن وجود عده مخابئ
لارهابيين انفصاليين من العرقيه البلوشيه
داخل الاراضي الايرانيه وانه تم اطلاع
الجانب الايراني على هذه المواقع ولم يتم
التعامل مع تلك التهديدات الارهابيه التي
تعاني منها باكستان من جانب ايران فاضطرت
باكستان لتنفيذ هذا الهجوم فجر هذا اليوم
ضد تلك المواقع وفي المعلومات الاخرى هذه
المعلومات كانت صادره كلها عن وزاره
الخارجيه لكن في المعلومات التي لدينا من
مصادر انه تم استهداف سته ست مواقع سته
اهداف داخل ثلاث مواقع بعمق حوالي 50 ر
داخل الاراضي الايرانيه بواسطه عده طائرات
عسكريه باكستانيه وانه تم اصابه تلك
الاهداف السته كلها بدرجه دقيقه وانه لا
يوجد هناك اي اضرار جانبيه يعني انه لم
تلحق اضرار بالمدنيين في تلك المناطق
المصادر الباكستانيه تؤكد بان الاصابات
كانت مباشره بينما وزاره الخارجيه
الباكستانيه في بها الرسمي لتنفيذ تلك
الضربات لم تتحدث عن التفاصيل التقنيه
المتعلقه بتلك الغارات وانما قالت بانه
كان من حق باكستان ان تتصرف بناء على عدم
تصرف وعدم اتخاذ الجانب الايراني اي تحرك
ضد تلك المواقع المنتشره داخل محافظه
سستان بلو سستان الايرانيه ابقى معي نور
الدين غير ايران كيف استقبلت هذا هذه
الضربات وقد اكد بيان الخارجيه
الباكستانيه على احترام سياده
ايران نعم محمد عمليا لحد الساعه على
المستوى الايراني ليس هناك الا حديث عن
انفجارات حدثت في منطقه سرفان في بعض
المناطق القريبه من الحدود الباكستانيه
والمساعد الامني لمحافظه سيسان و
وبلوشستان لحد الساعه يتحدث على ان الجهات
الامنيه والعسكريه بالم منطقه تجري
تحقيقاتها لمعرفه اسباب هذه الانفجارات
بمعنى نقول بان الجانب الايراني لحد
الساعه لا يتحدث عن هجمات او عن هجوم قامت
به القوات الباكستانيه وبان الامر الان هو
قيد التحقيق وقيد معرفه ملابسه هذه
الحادثه لكن اخر الاخبار والمستجدات
القادمه من هناك ودائما مع المساعد الامني
لمحافظه سيستان وب سستان يقول بان ان تلك
الانفجارات التي كانت هناك ادت الى مقتل
ثلاث نساء واربعه اطفال وكذلك اصابه تح
احداث نوع من الدمار في
بعض المباني السكنيه هناك
بالمنطقه لكن بكل تاكيد يمكن القول بان
هناك نوع من رد الفعل ربما قد نشهده من
قبل الجانب الباكستاني باتجاه ايران خاصه
بعد العمليه التي قامت بها ايران وقام بها
الحرس الثوري الايراني باستهداف بعد مقرات
جيش العدل داخل الاراضي الباكستانيه ايران
يمكن القول كذلك بانها حاولت ان تمتص بشكل
او باخر الغضب الايراني وخاصه على المستوى
الدبلوماسي حينما اجرى وزير الخارجيه
الايرانيه حسين امير عبد الله هيان اتصالا
هاتفيا مع ناظره الباكستاني امس والحديث
دائما عن هذا النوع من الت وتصر الخارجيه
الايرانيه عبد الله هيان اكد على ان ايران
تحترم سياده الاراضي الباكستانيه
لا وليس لديها اي شكوك في هذه المساله لكن
بكل تاكيد هنا الايرانيون يتحدثون على
انهم يتعاملون بشكل امني وبشكل عسكري مع
مصادر القلق ومصادر التهديد ويقول بان
مصادر التهديد كانت قادمه من تلك المناطق
من قبل جيش العدل خاصه اذا ما سجلنا ان
جيش العدل خلال الشهر الاخير قام بمجموعه
من العمليات العسكريه التي استهدفت مقرات
عسكريه ومقرات للشرطه ومقرات لقوات الحدود
الايرانيه وادت الى مقتل العديد
من القوات قوات الحدود حرس الحدود
الايرانيه وقوات الشرطه كذلك لا ننسى
العمليه التفجيريه التي حدثت في كيرمان
اثناء تخليد ذكرى مقتل القائد فلاق القدس
قاسم سليماني اذا كل هذه العوامل ربما
دفعت ايران للقيام بهذه العمليه تحركت
سياسيا لامتصاص الغضب الباكستاني لكن الان
الحديث عن تفجيرات على الحدود الباكستانيه
في منطقه منطقه رفان بالقرب من الحدود
الباكستانيه ربما قد تكون هناك بوادر ربما
الاخبار القادمه من باكستان بانها نفذت
العمليه لكن عمليا لحد الساعه الجانب
الايراني لا يتحدث عن هجمات باكستانيه
يتحدث عن انفجارات وبان التحقيقات جاريه
لمعرفه ملابسه هذه الانفجارات